el debate de este viernes entre Lula da
Silva y Yahir bolsonaro en Río de
Janeiro fue la última oportunidad de los
candidatos para traer electores cuando
falta apenas un día para que sean las
elecciones que podrían ser además las
más apretadas y las más tensas en la
historia del país en ese contexto
preguntamos a los ciudadanos Cuál es su
opinión sobre ese encuentro tan
emocional y con tantas respuestas
fuertes por parte y parte yo batch
no me gustó el debate realmente no me
gustó me pareció que fue muy agresivo
entre los candidatos
me pareció medio deprimente medio
deplorable porque era uno atacando al
otro no tuvo contenido no tuvo
propuestas
empeño de lo que se esperaba en primera
vuelta lo que los medios locales
reportan es que no ha habido grandes
modificaciones en su campaña que le
permitan hacer una mayor captación de
votantes Sin embargo aquí nada está
escrito lo que hicimos fue preguntarles
a los ciudadanos de a pie y el debate de
noche generó algún cambio en su voto
la democracia y voto es por Lula por la
democracia y es porque bolsonaron cada
vez más se fundamenta en mentiras en la
planificación que él dio a Brasil y
también a otros países hay medidas que
deben ser tomadas y que él deja en
debate entonces Mi voto es por nula
tan bosanar y es mía no cambió voy a
votar por bolsonaro y mis convicciones
siguen siendo las mismas porque yo me
alineo más con las pautas que él propone
sobre el otro candidato
A poco más de 24 horas de que Brasil
pueda proclamar es un nuevo ya fueron
movilizados todos los materiales
electorales todo está listo para que
mañana los votantes salgan masivamente a
emitir su voto por su candidato y el día
de hoy en Sao Paulo Pues será el cierre
de campaña de Lula da Silva por la
avenida paulista mientras que bolsonaro
hará su Cierre en Minas gerais